[Music]
Shawn it was such an amazing man and it
really is the love of my life and
actually hope one day that we can work
it out and get back together rumors have
been swirling that Nikki Bella and John
Cena have rekindled their romance after
calling off their engagement in April
that sucks there's no other way to say
that I want to make it sound nicer
prettier but a source tells et they are
not officially back together just yet in
fact according to the source the to have
hit a speed bump Cena is leaving the
country soon to film a new movie with
Dwayne Johnson for four months her
hidden talent is patience because she
puts up with me quote they're not the
kind of couple where its absence makes
the heart grow fonder they're more out
of sight out of mind so this distance
isn't going to be good for them adding
they work best when they're working
together and can be together all the
time
but the source tells e.t that the two
are still very much in love and hoping
to make it work they love each other
very much and can't imagine themselves
with anyone else they want to be
together and be happy but their priority
is very much on their careers right now
my biggest thing is I just want to
and hopefully ups together maybe it's
not but right now I'm just focusing on
you and really me
[Music]